hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for June 24 2009 teen what's going on
how are ya what's up how's everybody
doing are you having a nice week well
that's good that's good
I'll be I'm in a [ __ ] melancholy mood
I really am some [ __ ] going on
you know she get older things happen to
people that you love and it [ __ ]
sucks so with that we're gonna plow
through with that we're gonna plow
through we're gonna plow through we're
gonna bring the comedy through the pain
getting on this jokester train its Billy
and he's got on his clown makeup
Jesus Christ I didn't realize the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I was gonna stir up telling
that funny story about the club that
didn't put me on and then everybody
started going like you know that Club I
got to tell you they they do some things
that are not exactly things that you
might want to be doing to people so now
I'm kind of glad I didn't go up there
but anyway I've been I've been working
oh I've been working my new [ __ ] in 2530
minutes that I got since I did this
special not saying it's good not saying
it's it's deserves to be listened to by
human ears but they have to because
that's just how the game is played so I
went up the hell was I I was at the we
said I'm not even gonna say that comedy
clubs now because I don't wanna get
anybody in trouble but I was on stage
and you know the usual [ __ ] that happens
now when you do a [ __ ] comedy show is
everybody's having a great time and then
a younger white woman all of a sudden
has to [ __ ] be offended by something
right so I was joking about that and you
know then lo and behold I'm doing my set
and all of a sudden this woman starts
bitching about something I got the
classic there she is
the young white woman doesn't like the
joke the host showed us to stop and she
goes I'm not white
you know and the lights were in my eyes
it was like well you look white I can't
even see I go what are you she's like
I'm Asian
you should said it with a real attitude
I go well Jesus oh [ __ ] relax stop
acting like you've special this like six
billion are you sitting here talking
about yourself like you're a [ __ ]
albino alligator someone wants to make a
bag out of direct credit she laughed her
ass off now I know that was taken out of
context when on a comedy club you're
listening to this at home or maybe at
work
and maybe that offended you and you need
a hashtag something that was [ __ ]
funny she was cool though thank God she
ended up being cool but I tried out all
my new [ __ ]
and I actually was down in the village
afterwards and I've been working this
abortion angle and I got pro-choice
people I got him to give me an applause
break on something that was not
pro-choice on the [ __ ] issue which
made me feel great and just had a was
like the perfect night and then virzi
and Bobby Kelly were there and we went
oh my gotta tell this [ __ ] story
so furs gets a like a box of [ __ ]
Cuban cigars as did I we both a buddy of
ours got a house [ __ ] he doesn't even
know this yet he's gonna know now he got
us his box of Cuban cigars and he sent
us pictures going what do you want you
want all Cubans or do you want this mix
of Cuban cigars right so I'm like well
I'll take the mix you know I'll take the
whole smorgasbord
right so Mersey I like verse he didn't
know the same guy you know it's a buddy
of ours he paid us both up and sent us
and we you know he didn't have us on the
same like tax change so neither one of
us knew he goes dude I got up I got the
variety bucks I go did you get it from
so-and-so he goes yeah and it goes great
so I'll meet you down the cellar right
he goes I had Cubans and we're all
excited right I go down I do a couple
two three sets I have a great sets versi
[ __ ] murder
heard by the wavers he's gonna be at
laughs Boston this weekend please go out
and see this guy man
okay [ __ ] this guy's the real deal
and like he has turned a [ __ ] corner
and he is not the same comic when he
headlines that he is when he's open and
for me there's a whole other level that
he goes to just because he has the time
to really work ideas and I'm so thrilled
for him and watching you know there's
nothing I enjoy better than seeing a
comic you know all of a sudden they got
like that growth they turn the corner
and all that you know inspires you to
[ __ ] try and push yourself and yada
yada yada and all that right so anyway
so we're gonna alter that ball so
reminds me when we were sitting in the
park Bobby Kelly was gone Jesus Christ I
had to go in after Jessica Kirsten and I
was like oh man that's a tough that's a
rough one he goes yeah he goes she can
like she goes dude she's like three
comics and one she can do voices and I
even I jumped on earth I go she can be
big she can just be standing there she's
got like every tool in the [ __ ]
toolbox and by the way oh what a
coincidence all things comedy produced
her upcoming special along with Ian
Edwards another beast so it was just a
great night so we're upstairs at the
cellar about ready to go over there and
Bobby's into cigars too and what you
have to understand about Bobby Kelly is
Bobby when Bobby gets into [ __ ] they're
more Tom Cruise was talking about
Scientology and he was just like I
[ __ ] get into [ __ ] you know which is
the reference we used on f is for family
when when when Vic Reynolds go I get
into [ __ ] that was a nod to him flying
helicopters whatever Tom Cruise does you
know this stunt to be done next thing
you know they're duck taking them to the
side of a [ __ ] 747 I mean lunatic but
in a good way
cuz you get to enjoy what the [ __ ] they
do right and I was gonna say so Bobby's
the same way right and he gets into [ __ ]
he [ __ ] gets into [ __ ] so he got into
cigars
all right I'm into cigars but like I'm
not like one of these [ __ ] people
like you know I'm not like a connoisseur
you know I know about some cigars but
like any one of you out there could
educate me on this is a Connecticut leaf
and all of that goes guys and they light
them and they're like oh no I'm - eight
minutes of hints of chili pepper with it
with some chocolate of some chocolate
aftertaste it [ __ ] drives me up the
wall because first of all they know what
the [ __ ] they're gonna say before they
light they lit it they already took it
and it's like they're lighting it and
they're already hearing feeling hints of
this and hints of that like they're this
[ __ ] five-star chef the [ __ ] out of
here
all right you like cigar I've ever lit
whereas I was lighting it I was like oh
my god was a any Cuban cigar I've ever
smoked that was actually real so anyway
we're at the cellar and first he's like
I got Cubans and Bobby said he got
Cubans yeah or maybe I was excited so
Bobby's just sitting there right like
the [ __ ] dawn of cigars he's sitting
it you know like when that guy in
Goodfellas comes in he has a problem
with this restaurant
he's just so only want me to I don't
know what the restaurant is right so big
fuzzy I mean Bobby just goes let me see
him so rosy gives him the Box he glances
at the cigars and immediately he puts it
he puts on his glasses and he lifts he
leaves looking on the side of the box
he's not looking at the cigars and I
immediately knew what he was gonna do I
was like oh no he put on his glasses
that I swear to God looked like the
windshield on a [ __ ] motor scooter
east lens giant [ __ ] glasses and that
was not in a lit room was not enough he
then took the flashlight on his phone
and puts it on the serial number and as
he was doing in my head I'm like don't
do this Bobby please don't ruin the
night before it begins and he looks at
me just and he just puts the Box down
shuts off the light takes off his
glasses and looks at first he just goes
these are fake
Rosie's going like now oh they're not no
they're not he goes now that fake he
goes every Cuban cigar they come with
the serial number Bobby knew what the
serial number was and he's like these
are fake okay so I'm [ __ ] dying
laughing mercy mercy is like mercy is
like he's like Santa Claus you know this
is what you need to know about Paul big
Paul Mercy's heart is he every year no
matter what the Knicks do he still has
hope the next season he is first virzi
is Christmas the whole [ __ ] year
around right sober Z shoulders literally
like slump I mean I got on oh they're
probably good whatever go to get the
same we're walking out and I just look
at by I got buff why would you do that
he's like what do you do if a kid go
that's but Papa go that's not how you do
it and he starts laughing I go this is
what you should have done you should
have realized they were fake and then
what you do is just sit there smoke them
tell them that they're good and then in
a couple weeks show up you know to go
smoke with the guy say by the way you
know those Cuban cigars you had a few
weeks ago and he goes yeah it go by the
way those within will those weren't real
they were fake and then you pull out and
go but here's here's a real one okay and
then you could educate him on the serial
number and all that so Bobby goes
alright fair enough fair enough right
and then burrs egos yet do it I don't
think these are fake he starts it back
up again forever the hopeful Nick fan he
starts it back up again and at that
point ago our I Paul not now like now I
gotta turn my back on you Paul Sorvino
I gotta turn my back I tried to [ __ ]
stick up for the moment and it's over so
then we ended up but we wind up going to
that park right across the street from
Joe's pizza the one you see at the end
of Ray Romano is amazing special if you
haven't watched it yet so at that point
we were all just laughing and I was like
Bob which one do you want do you want
the pho Heba or the fart agus you know
basically using the Cuban names but
saying F for fake and we were all just
laughing but they actually smoked good
and
didn't taste that bad and then a buddy
of ours ended up showing up we had like
the [ __ ] best night sitting there
smoking the cigar looking at the
ridiculously long line over at Joe's
waiting for it to get small enough that
we were going to go over there and get a
slice of pizza and I I wasn't going to
get a slice because I've been eating too
many and I got to keep my girlish figure
here for the for the motion-picture all
right I don't want my [ __ ] I don't
want my [ __ ] second trimester
alabaster belly taken away from the true
star of the show which is my mustache so
we just sat there the whole night then
we just started talking about how much
money do you think Joe's is make it and
[ __ ] you know my dad always wanted to
open a pizza parlor virzi wanted to open
a pizza parlor and all that [ __ ] we just
sat there shooting the [ __ ] and just I
came in like it was a grown-up's thing's
a classic great cigar where it was just
like great cigar hang I should say
before Bobby calls it dude it was he
great deal with fake did did that
conversation in the park had a serial
number on it that wasn't real that
wasn't real conversation we just said we
talked comedy that's what we're we were
talking about assets and Bobby was
talking about having to follow Jessica
and I don't just had like the greatest
the greatest [ __ ] night and I don't
know it's why you know as much as a good
time as I had drinking booze for all
those years I can kind of walk away from
that because you know there's an
inebriation obviously involved with
boozing even if you just have a couple
and a lot of great conversation is lost
but was to go at but even then I gotta I
gotta go easy on the cigars okay this
whole talk is making me want to smoke
one right now but I will tell you last
night I went out and I did big J's skank
fest I never you know so it's funny is I
never really put that today I know what
that word means but I never because it
fest at the end of it like you can call
something [ __ ] fest and when I showed up
and there was an orgy there I would
still be surprised like once once fest
is at the end of it that the prefix is
no longer as a single word anymore it's
just the beginning of it and a doesn't
doesn't even dawn on me and I'm not
saying that there was a bunch of skanks
there but it was just like it reminded
me the energy was like when you used to
do those Opie and Anthony live events
where it was crazy
maniacal fans with ridiculously awesome
loyalty and it was slightly scary so we
went up there and we played we did the
goddamn comedy Jim and I got to take by
the time I went up there Josh Adam
Meyers it looked like somebody had
thrown him in an above-ground pool with
his clothes on he was absolutely
drenched in sweat I've never seen all
these people hardest-working man in show
business I never saw anybody sweating
like that he was absolutely soaked his
shorts his shirt his hair the whole
[ __ ] thing he looked like a [ __ ]
like I said he looked like someone just
threw him in a [ __ ] pool and we went
up there and I haven't had a lot of time
to play on a kit because did I mention
I'm doing a movie 550 times in this
[ __ ] thing a right though we get it
for once you're working as an actor but
I did I went out and I bought a practice
pad and I've been working on my hands
there trying to remember some [ __ ] that
day village Elitch taught me and just
doing that I think I played the best
I've I've played I mean still saying I'm
not saying it was good but I wasn't
nervous or anything so of course I
played you do better if you weren't
nervous but I got to play kickstart my
heart with old the teen idol sensation
from the Opie and Anthony program Joe
DeRosa came back out and saying
kickstart my heart and it
didn't dawn on me till afterwards when I
left that was like wait a minute I
finally got to jam with [ __ ] Joe
DeRosa and dude the crowd was [ __ ]
insane
they were [ __ ] it's I don't know if
you've seen some of the clips from it
but like Bobby Kelly crowd-surf de
l'année at a podcast Bobby these Cubans
aren't real Kelly anyway and then we
played a Pantera I'm broken
aka downtown comedy club downtown comedy
club which we don't even call it I'm
broken anymore now Josh goes you want to
do downtown yeah we'll do downtown and
then Joey roses is going to sing
kickstart my heart and it was like it
was [ __ ] awesome I could barely hear
the guitar in the bass but I was just
sort of humming the song along so I you
know there was a couple of minor train
wrecks in there that were my fault but I
think overall when I was on it I
actually played it pretty good so I was
very excited about that so then I go to
run out of it because there was no place
to hang out I mean it was like it was a
[ __ ] free-for-all in the greatest
sense I think everybody there you just
walked in and had a backstage pass
I wanted the green room there was like
400 [ __ ] people in there it felt like
but honestly it was probably like I know
upwards of 30 people in a room that
comfortably would have held seven so
that was the only part trying to figure
out a place where I could stand and kind
of think about you know the song so I
didn't blow it and you know I got to see
some of red bands stand-up show
downstairs who the [ __ ] that I see Josh
went up and did a set Tony the show pony
I got to see him he had a great bit
about transgendered athletes and yeah I
think that that was it so anyway
afterwards and this [ __ ] venue by the
way Jesus Christ I mean
you could have shot a horror movie in
this place it was out of the 70s and
literally nothing had been changed I
mean we were in the sober green room we
finally found one downstairs and what
was hilarious we walked in there was one
person there so we went in there and
they had these these round rounded like
leather sort of cheap-ass looking
minimalist chairs unlike these literally
look like they're from the set of like
Mary Tyler Moore's apartment but anyway
we had we ended up having a great time
so I do this I do the show right play
kick start in downtown comedy club right
and they had a great [ __ ] time I get
off stage and I'm gonna overwrite and I
go outside and there's this lime-green
taxi sitting there as if I had already
called it I'm like what a [ __ ]
perfect night you know I get to do big
J's [ __ ] festival I I [ __ ] jam
with Joe DeRosa I don't [ __ ] up the
songs too bad everything goes great and
here's a cab waiting for me I said yeah
you want and he's like yes right and I
go to get in and ie goes where you're
going and I was like I'm going to 81st
and 3rd he's like 80 first and third I
go yeah in Manhattan
he's like Manhattan yeah Manhattan 8 1 &
3 I go yes Manhattan I'm like yeah New
York City Empire State Building if I can
make it there right and then I'm
thinking like oh my god we're in
Brooklyn he doesn't want to go all the
way out there
he's a lime green cab he's gonna have to
drive back empty so I just I [ __ ] say
to the guy do you not want to go and he
goes no no how do you want to go Midtown
Tunnel you want to take the Williamsburg
Bridge and I'm like whatever you think
is faster you want to go Midtown
Williamsburg I got whichever 81 and 3
and I just go to go [ __ ] yourself and I
got a [ __ ]
Jim I knew what he was doing but I had
to commend it the fact that in a second
language he still knew how to play dumb
so he could get what the [ __ ] he wanted
it was such passive-aggressive horseshit
but I got I have to commend him that it
did work then he had the audacity as I'm
standing there across the street waiting
for my uber he was he was outside of his
car leaning on his car just looking at
me likes like the guy that Clint
Eastwood kills in a Western you know I
mean like you know what I mean you can
just tell like this guy's just gonna be
a dick I mean maybe he was mad at me but
I didn't overreact because I went to get
out of his cab and I was waitin no way
at the butt and he didn't do it he just
let me get out [ __ ] [ __ ]
by the way my temper is back in full
force because I have not [ __ ] gone to
therapy and been able to talk about my
and the big thing about it's been
helping me about the therapy is I'm
always thinking in my head like well if
I talk about this then I have to go in
and talk to her and say that I failed
this week now I don't have that I don't
have the parameters so I got a I got a I
got to get it back under control I mean
it does make for great stories here in
the podcast I am mattress this [ __ ]
guy said like nine times a day one and
three it's just like dude your entire
country is better at math than some of
our best students over here okay we've
got a couple of aging Asian free agents
but do generally white people you crush
us in math you know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about
so anyway I got a couple of days off
here and I got to go to a barber and get
this [ __ ] mustache trimmed because it
is like gonna be hanging down below my
bottom lip here and I'm like I can't do
what everything gets in it I don't know
how the [ __ ] the level of commitment to
having one of these [ __ ] hipster
[ __ ] Sam Elliott mustaches is it
starting to get it's starting to wear on
me all right Oh Billy Dallas buyers club
here is has had it so I got you know I
think I wrap the second week in August
and I'm gonna clear it with the director
and be like alright dude I'm gonna go
home and shave this off are we cool
because it's gonna take me you know six
to seven weeks to grow this [ __ ] again
yeah I'm gonna go back to being Billy
red-faced I miss that guy did anybody
watch the f1 race I actually caught it
caught it and I watched it in Spanish
and even in Spanish I knew the [ __ ]
race was over the second Lewis Hamilton
may you know right as they say it's a
race to the first turn and I'll tell you
I couldn't believe that that Lewis
Hamilton had won the pole and valtteri
botas was in second place it's
unbelievable I mean I thought the other
ninety weeks in a row that they've
seemed to have done that was just a
fluke dude a level of driver of Lewis
Hamilton in the level of car that he's
in and he's in the pole position and he
gets the first turn I can tell you this
like there's no point in watching the
rest of the [ __ ] race it's you how
they even like televised the race they
they're not even showing Lewis Hamilton
then I even showing the guy in first
place they spend the whole race showing
like [ __ ] third fourth and fifth
those people jockeying for position
that's where the racing is but it's
still an incredible sport but I got to
tell you like they need to there's gonna
have to be some something they have to
do something all right there's got to be
that something's got to give here we're
like you know in hockey they got rid of
the red line so you could have the
stretch pass to somehow beat that
[ __ ] you know trap defense which now
is going to be can you beat a trap
defense while they're running your
goaltender and [ __ ] cross-checking
you in the teeth like those piece of
[ __ ] saying Louis Blues it's gradually
going to come out because I wanted to be
classy when they want filthy filthy
[ __ ] team but you know Bruins have
had filthy teams that's how I'm making
my peace with it but it just kills me we
should have run their [ __ ] mediocre
goddamn goaltender which by the way now
that you've had your parade because I
don't want to rain on your parade now
that it's gone dude
that [ __ ] horse [ __ ] where they were
does but more games that [ __ ]
that that [ __ ] guy if we scored the
first [ __ ] goal the guy let up ten
goals in two games it was pulled out of
one game everybody [ __ ] relax all
right you got a matt cassel situation he
gets traded to the hockey equivalent of
the Chiefs ten years ago and that guy's
a [ __ ] sieve I haven't said that
congratulations on your cup the [ __ ] was
his goals against ten goals in two
[ __ ] games jesus [ __ ] christ and
they're just sitting there ball washing
the guy these are reason why is he I
thought it was the [ __ ] goons he had
in front of him [ __ ] taking runs at
people and boarding everybody I thought
it was that call me crazy anyways where
am i let's read some advertising here
alright oh good news and better news
here
I was actually home I was visiting as I
sort of alluded to one of my friends is
gravely ill and you know that's never
fun but I did go back and I met up with
a bunch of my high school buddies who
I've still been in touch with thirty
some odd years and we we hung out and we
were all talking about the hangover of
when the NHL and the NBA playoffs end
because there's such high anything oh
god let's watch a baseball game is born
ago now I put it on settlement settling
it's [ __ ] great it's a great [ __ ]
game right and we happened to watch that
Red Sox game where you're down forward
enough against the Blue Jays and we came
back and won seven to five and ten
innings ended up being a great game and
we were talking about the old days and
all of that [ __ ] and I read the next day
in the Boston sports page which I never
get to read anymore
I think I have a subscription to both
the globe and The Herald I just don't
remember my passwords
they were talking about our coach was it
Cora I'm so not a baseball guy right now
our managers decision I guess we brought
a pitcher in and we walked somebody to
get to a guy who was four four four for
the night and everyone was scratching
their heads but the pitcher we had was
the guy had gone over three lifetime
against him so everybody thought that he
walked him because the four four four
guy he had never got a hit on our
pitcher and he's in our manager was like
that's not why I did it I did it because
he was four for four
and it's almost you know it's really
difficult to go five for five so he was
betting on the fact that all right this
guy got four hits but there's no way
he's getting five I never heard anybody
do the math like that in baseball and
somehow it worked out so I know we're
not playing the greatest baseball and
the Yankees are absolutely on wire on
fire and now they're and they won't even
play with their best guys so I'm
definitely gonna be keeping an eye on
that because as I keep mentioning the
Yankees win it this year who they got it
as good a chance as anybody
like I said they will keep the day they
will have won at least one World Series
in nine of the last ten decades no yeah
unbelievable
that's un-fuckin'-believable to be that
successful for that long and even as a
Red Sox fan you have to give it up too
and congratulations to the Blues there's
just a few things I was just biting my
tongue watching that [ __ ] [ __ ]
because I didn't want to be the [ __ ]
sore loser but here I am two weeks later
still [ __ ] steaming over did you see
what the Bruins drafted to drafted a
[ __ ] six foot three 200 something
pound [ __ ] Center I told you that's
what we needed we didn't have that power
forward to stand there in the slot
that's what we needed so we were passing
wing to [ __ ] wing and that amazing
Patrick walk Junior he went from one
post to the other alright honey
today's show is brought to you by honey
the easiest way to save money when
you're shopping online honestly before I
found out about honey honey see the
promo
honestly before I found out about honey
seeing the promo code box at checkout
stressed me out yeah anything on
computer stresses me up honey we'll have
you find lab we'll find you every coupon
code sale or discount on over 20,000
sites like Amazon j.crew eBay Macy's
Sephora and Nordstrom and more do you
realize this is literally built for guys
like me
who are afraid of computers and can't
figure out where I mean I can't even use
the [ __ ] stove the oven I figured out
the stove but the oven I couldn't even
figure I couldn't figure out how to
raise the temperature so then I had to
do the math all right 25 minutes at 400
I can only get it to be the standard 350
here what is that like 32 minutes let me
just hit you on off and I had the
[ __ ] numbers it wasn't any easier
than that why does it have to have a
digital [ __ ] code you know why that
is it's because they just want to keep
getting you to keep buying the next
[ __ ] thing to remind me to talk about
cardio machines after this read here
honey we'll find you every coupon sale a
discount on over on over 20,000 sites
like Amazon j.crew eBay Macy's Sephora
Nordstrom and more we've got your back
so you might ask how do I know honey has
my back does it really work well not
only did honey's test over 1 billion
promo codes last year but it actually
applied 185 million 67,000 no sorry yeah
185 million 67,000 86 working codes to
people's orders that's a lot of real
life savings just it is not to mention
over 10 million people are already
saving with honey and it has over
100,000 five-star reviews the google
chrome store on the google chrome store
thanks to honey
now there's literally no stress when I
see that promo code at checkout please
interject personal experience of how
honey has saved you I haven't used it
yet I want to use it I got to get it
where do I get it
look there's no reason not to use honey
it's free it's [ __ ] free which means
the advertisers are given them money
these people are you're gonna buy from
they take the [ __ ] hit right is that
how it works
- just bring all of us there it's free
to use and easy to install any computer
in just two clicks never overthink the
promo code again get honey for free at
join honeycomb / / that's joined
honeycomb / / honey online savings
simplified what do we got here ah look
who's here it's hymns hymns you've heard
us talking about him and how they are
helping guys look their best if you
haven't yet it's time to see what
they're all about 66% of men's start
losing their hair by age 35 once you've
noticed thin hair it can be too late
is that hairline slowly starting to move
backwards any bald spots yet the best
way to prevent more hair loss is to do
something about it while you still have
some it's time to get a handle on those
precious locks do you want to do you
want a bald spot to pop up on your
hairline - wait do you want a bald spot
to pop up or your hairline to recede or
do you want to do something about it
first from my personal experience it's
better to have a receding hairline than
to be losing in the back you lose it in
the back you're gonna meet in the middle
in the middle of your head that's the
way it's gonna go for him calm if you
lose it in the front you can kind of
just keep combing it forward for a while
and look like you're in a [ __ ] cover
band for the Beatles but do you really
want to do that why don't you just go to
four hymns calm a one-stop-shop for hair
loss skin care sexual wellness for men
no more awkward in-person doctor visits
or long pharmacy lines for him connects
you to real doctors online which could
save you hours completely confidential
and discreet answers a few quick
questions a doctor will review and if
they determine it's right for you you
can can prescribe you medication to
treat hair loss that is shipped directly
to your door get the hair loss treatment
everyone is talking about featured in GQ
Men's Health Esquire and playboy to name
a few my listeners can get started with
the hems complete hair kit for just 5
bucks right now while supplies last and
subject to doctor's approval I don't
know what that means
see website for full details and safety
information this could cost hundreds if
you went to the doctor or our pharmacy
or somewhere else go to for hims dot-com
/ / that's fo r hims com / / that's for
hims calm / BER you don't have actually
fascinated with rock bands all male rock
bands where nobody loses their hair you
know I mean that can't be real
somebody must have done it for hims you
know you look at Aerosmith they all got
their hair you look at the Rolling
Stones they all got their hair Keith was
starting to lose it you know we started
wearing the bandanas and then we got
Johnny Depp doing the [ __ ] Pirates of
the Caribbean because of that going this
guy's dressing like a pirate I think he
was doing the LeBron James he was
wearing the [ __ ] headband and then I
don't know I just saw him recently and
he got it back he looked like he had a
[ __ ] decaying bird's nest on his head
for a long time and being the fact that
he was a smoker I was really concerned
for you know when he was [ __ ] lighting
it up you know if they but all of a
sudden one of the Amber's there you know
like how like those those LA fires the
Amber's will float over other houses and
just [ __ ] unfortunate land on
somebody else's house and someone's
sitting there across the street looking
at three houses that burnt down and
their whole block they're all [ __ ] a
side of the block is fine it's like a
tornado we got it bill all right
butchers bucks this month butcher Box is
offering free bacon for life sign up now
and you'll get one package of the best
tasting bacon free in every box for you
can't imagine me in the Rolling Stones
and you don't lose your hair and you got
great [ __ ] hair it's just like you
know you got to be thinking what did I
do in a past life this much puts
butchers boxes offering free bacon for
life sign up now and you get one package
of the best tasting baking free free in
every box for life for the life of your
subscription butcher box bacon is whole
30 approved uncured nitrate and sugar
free right now new member
we'll get a package of bacon for free in
every box for the life of your
subscription plush you get $20 off your
first box ah this is that all of this
stuff is my favorite out of everybody
who's advertised every month butcher box
delivers 100% grass-fed and
grass-finished beef free-range organic
organic chicken and my favorite heritage
breed pork the best pork chop I've ever
made and while the last can salmon
directly to your door the incredible
quality of butcher box meat starts with
the commitment to humanely raised
animals that are never fed antibiotics
or hormones before they get whacked like
Joe Pesci and [ __ ] Goodfellas do we
mention it's delivered right to your
door choose from four curated boxes
including a mix of high quality
grass-fed grass-finished beef free-range
organic chicken and heritage breed pork
or customize your own box so you can get
exactly what you and your family love
butcher box also has wild Cod Alaskan
salmon sockeye salmon what did you call
me I just said it Laskin salmon I
thought you called me a sockeye salmon
and put your box bacon that is sourced
from heritage breed pigs and is uncured
nitrate free and sugar free by the way
if you didn't know what heritage breed
pork pigs are they can trace their
bloodline back to Europe these are pure
bred pigs the best of the best when it
comes to pork alright they aren't the
bastardized version over here like me
where I'm you know I'm German Irish
Scottish Dutch French right I think I
got a little English in there I know
what the [ __ ] it is now these are 100%
European [ __ ] pigs I don't know what
they do to the European pigs over there
I don't know if it's the [ __ ] DJ
music you know the house music they
listen to I don't know what the [ __ ] it
is the EDM but they just taste better
than the ones over here that are
listening to our [ __ ] you know my
favorite cut is on this is a pork chop
without a doctor heritage bread pork
there's no easier way to get
high-quality meat you can trust there's
no commitment and you can cancel at any
time for C $20 off your first box box
and a package of free bacon in every box
for the life of your subscription go to
butcher box com / / enter
at checkout go now it's a limited time
offer good lord at everybody is there
anything more American than a package of
free bacon in every boxing whatever
subscription you have all right let's
talk cardio machines because that's what
I've been doing and this friend of mine
was claiming there was a new cardio
machine where he's burning way more
calories than you do on an elliptical at
the same amount of time and it just
dawned on me I was just like that's just
sort of like the scam with cardio
equipment is that once people buy
something they're so [ __ ] expensive
it's like they're not gonna you know my
mother bought a [ __ ] NordicTrack in
the late 80s she's still using it still
works up a sweat and all of that [ __ ]
right she got it for my dad he never
[ __ ] used it and she uses it right so
the thing about that game is is in order
to get people to buy again you have to
you have to somehow come up with some
sort of device that is it's burning more
calories in a shorter amount of time all
right and the thing about that is it
just it just says enter your age enter
your weight and what else does something
else I don't know what the [ __ ] it is
and then it just says well you burn this
many calories it's like don't you need
more information than that I don't have
a [ __ ] science background obviously
I'm not a personal trainer
obviously Hey right but I said like what
do you what the [ __ ] you do and I think
they just fudged the [ __ ] numbers to
drive the market so I just looked up I
just looked up cardio machines scam and
I found this [ __ ] article first of
all first of all it was funny was most
of them were trying to sell you cardio
equipment and this article that I end up
reading this guy was breaking down
all the ways why those things are just
they're not accurate because it's
basically like if some if I was to get
on a cardio machine in the shape that
I'm in and work out at a certain level
like it's it's gonna be challenging to
my body type right if someone else of
like the exact same whatever proportions
as me who on paper we are the same but
they they have more like athletic DNA or
whatever and they barely break a sweat
they're gonna say that they [ __ ] burn
the same thing like everybody's like
different you would need you need so
much more [ __ ] information and I
really just feel like the whole [ __ ]
thing is a scam I'm not saying cardio
machines are bad I'm just saying buy one
and if it still [ __ ] works don't get
suckered into buying something else this
guy wrote a whole article just on
elliptical machine saying it's the most
useless thing and that's the one that I
use and he was saying that they're
absolutely [ __ ] useless cuz at least
a Stairmaster
is something you can apply in real life
walking up stairs are going up a [ __ ]
Hill a rowing machine you know for when
you take your lilia [ __ ] the love of
your life around a lake I don't know who
the [ __ ] rose anymore if you're escaping
Alcatraz you know and you made a [ __ ]
dinghy out of a [ __ ] pair of pants
and some shirts that you tied together
what else but like yeah an elliptical
like unless I got oh I don't want you
get cross-country ski I have no [ __ ]
idea I don't know what the point of any
of that was oh the point was that my
buddy was going you got to get on this
thing it burns way more calories and I'm
just you know being a pessimistic son of
a [ __ ] isn't the greatest thing in life
but like it does prevent you from going
out and falling for [ __ ] like that it's
like how do they know how the [ __ ] do
they know what the [ __ ] you're burning
you just tell them your age and your
weight they don't know how much of that
is fat how much of that is muscle you
don't have to say how tall you are and
most of them right do you have a little
fat [ __ ] and then a tall skinny guy and
they're trying to say that they burn the
same calories you know the fatties
almost dying and it all stretch over
there he's barely
breaking a sweat dad I'll tell you all
right let's uh let's do some of the
reads here for the week how much time
have I done here only I don't like about
this new [ __ ] one it's difficult to
figure that all right 41 minutes in okay
Whoopi and Bella Thorne from a lady all
right so last week I was talking about
Whoopi's response to this this celebrity
who would send some naked photos to her
boyfriend and they were on the cloud and
some [ __ ] got him and then he tried
to blackmail her and then Whoopi was
just like what the [ __ ] you doing that
for you famous and I was like that's
exactly what my mother would have said
hey Billy bald [ __ ] this is from a lady
I love when the lady's right in the
thing about what Whoopi said is that I
think thorne realizes she made a mistake
we'll be just jumping in like hey
dumbass that was dumb I'm older and
smile I'm older yeah look at that look
at that you throw in a little shade her
way and smarter than you you shouldn't
have been so dumb isn't helpful that's
not what she said that's not what she
said all right she goes if I went
swimming and lost a foot to a shark you
know that's a great comparison I think
that you know uploading naked photos of
yourself that somebody black man you
look [ __ ] great by the way I didn't
see him but like I saw Joy Behar was
going like I've had a body like that I'd
[ __ ] blast him around the subway
I love joy by the way I got to work with
her on crashing she's [ __ ] hilarious
she goes if I went swimming and lost a
foot to a shark and the paramedic just
comes up and says hey [ __ ]
you should have known sharks are in the
ocean I'm not going to check if you're
all right
just need you to know you were an idiot
I [ __ ] realize I made a mistake you
don't need to publicly chastise me all
right that that that right there first
of all what you're saying Whoopi said
she didn't say and then this this
comparison is not the same thing okay
a paramedics job is to come up to you if
you're bleeding is to stop the bleeding
to get you to the doctors at the
hospital while you're still alive that
his job Whoopi's job is not to make this
person feel better okay and she didn't
say hey dumbass that was dumb I'm older
and smarter than you you shouldn't be so
dumb that's not what she said okay and
the thing about you [ __ ] people about
people in general is you know when you
[ __ ] up in life if somebody doesn't hold
your feet to the fire speaking of feet
you're not gonna learn anything if
people are just constantly coddling you
alright you don't learn anything and
then secondly this is a famous person
famous people are not people they are
just things that people use to get
through ten minutes of their [ __ ] day
on a radio show or a [ __ ] blog that
they don't feel like doing that day so
part of being in the public eye is
getting trashed alright at the [ __ ]
pathetic level then I'm at alright
I sigh literally I stopped reading
comments on social media years ago
because it's literally like like 80%
negative that's basically what happens
alright but what I liked about what
Whoopi said was it was old-school
parenting alright yeah you [ __ ] up
just cuz you're [ __ ] up doesn't mean
you deserve a hug and somebody cries on
your shoulder I'm not saying that you
don't deserve that
okay but somebody also needs to like you
know if you're just like oh my god this
happened and I'm a victim and somebody
just goes yeah that's so terrible oh my
god I hope you're okay like what did you
learn if you take a jump shot at the end
of the game when there was a guy
underneath and you missed the [ __ ]
shot and everybody boos you and then
you're in the locker room crying is the
coach not supposed to bring up that the
was a guy open underneath that had a way
higher percentage of a shot next time
you get into that [ __ ] situation you
know I will say this what she didn't do
in the end was what a great coach would
do is after he gave his [ __ ] for [ __ ]
up he would then built don't worry
you'll get him next time but bah bah bah
bah bah all right I will give you that
she didn't do that but it was refreshing
to have somebody like hold somebody
[ __ ] responsible for their [ __ ]
actions I mean it was a little
ridiculous that you're just gonna
[ __ ] that you're gonna do something
like that I know she is younger I don't
[ __ ] I don't I don't know but I mean
I don't know listen I'm not even saying
Whoopi was right all I knew was it made
me miss my mom well what'd you do that
for you idiot she always used to do that
you know well that's what you get for
climbing a tree I mean you got to hang
on
all right Saturday dear Billy linguine
mystics greetings from Rome ah what am I
gonna great trips I ever took you're
constantly emphasizing the Oh a today
and Saturday with a Boston accent is
that from something or is it just how
Boston drunks talk when they're Boston
level drunk love your music choices well
that's Andrew That's not me
Andrew makes the music choices oh hey
hey I'm gonna come over there on say
it's an exact it's an exaggeration of
Saturday and there's some people say
Saturday
that's what it is why don't you come
over on Saturday we'll figure it out you
know it's like really a hardier Boston
accent so me and my buddies being living
in LA and missing the Boston accent
exaggerated to the point that became say
hey but it's much go this Saturday
my mother-in-law came over this past
Saturday
if she was in rare form that's where it
comes from it just comes from well it
really comes from yeah being there and
then also watching Steve Sweeney making
fun of the Boston accent and when all of
us comics from the Boston sea scene all
ended up in LA at the same time that was
you know it was you know it was a
[ __ ] culture shock to go from Boston
all the way out to LA it's just so
[ __ ] different both great cities and
I love both of them but we were young
and we just you know we didn't know
anything our whole lives were spent in
Massachusetts New Hampshire Maine all of
these guys that I moved out there with
roughly the same time so the way we
dealt with Holmes being homesick is we
hung out with each other and as we were
starting to lose our Boston accents like
as much as I still have one that's it's
not it's not even remotely what it used
to be I have a very soft Boston accent
if you can believe that so some of them
be like going yeah we just say something
like that would be like yeah dude I
gotta wash my car today and blah blah
blah washer what and they'd be like car
what and he go yeah that's what we just
said we'd always like when we heard
somebody pronounce an R we were just I
don't know why we would do that it was
[ __ ] stupid but uh I remember one of
the hardest laughs I ever had when I was
out there in LA we were doing time in
this now-defunct the LA Cabaret yeah I
came in what the [ __ ] it was called it
was just way out in the valley this
[ __ ] comedy club it was in this strip
mall I forget what it was called but we
were out there and Bob Marley was on
stage and he was talking about moving
across the country with his wife and he
was telling the story and like there was
like eight people there and like seven
of them were comedians it was ridiculous
it was like nobody there and he was
standing there and he's gone yeah when
we moved across country and he goes we
took a [ __ ] any
jumped up in the air jumped up the air
and landed in this squat position he
goes we took a [ __ ] ride
you know the Ryder truck and it was just
so silly and ridiculous and we were all
so frustrated that we weren't getting
good stage time a lot of us thinking
what the [ __ ] had we done that we just
fell out laughing and is funny like he
did that well over 20 years ago and I
never forgot it and to this day when I
Drive down the street and I see they're
not yellow anymore because the [ __ ]
idiots in the world trade I believe they
switched them to white whenever I see
one I always think of that every time
it's just a joke that keeps giving all
right dealing with parents hey Bill
loved the podcasts in your standup sorry
he had a bad experience at the airport
last time you were here in India hope
you come again sometime I didn't date I
didn't have like a bad I had a
terrifying experiences I didn't think
they're gonna let me out anyways they
put the S air I'm 18 and recently got
accepted in a well respected Engineering
College
you see exactly a b18 one you know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about in India but
I don't want to follow that career I
want to be a mechanic that's cool man
being a mechanic is [ __ ] cool I
contacted and scored an internship at a
huge Kustoms garage in Mumbai
dude that's a [ __ ] no-brainer the
problem is my parents told Jesus they
are forcing me to go to engineering
schools as it is safer choice according
to them they want me to take up computer
science my father brings one of his
successful friends home every day and
together they try to convince me my
parents are not bad people and I believe
they did a decent job raising me and
I've always supported me but this time
they just won't listen how do you think
I should talk to them and explain my
passion about cars and machines also
would like to know your thoughts on max
Verstappen Thanks
dude you got to follow your heart and
sometimes your parents
you know what I've learned is being a
parent the short amount of time that I
have is that there's an unbelievable
amount of fear the fear if this is
possible almost it is bigger than the
love you it's like recup is because you
love them so much that you this fear
that something bad is going to happen to
them so what they're worried about is
they they know that you know you're
gonna outlive them right so they're
worried they just want to know that
you're gonna be okay after they're gone
so that's where they're coming from if
that helps you understand it more and
maybe you can come with us and I know
that you guys are worried about my
future and you know I you know I get
that or whatever and just like you want
me to be happy right this is what's
gonna make me happy I absolutely love
this I have a pass for this I would do
this for free and I know I'm gonna be
good enough with the great you know
jeans that I have from you guys that I
got accepted to engineering school that
like I can apply this not the brains
that you gave me to this thing and I'll
be one of the best guys out there just
talk yourself up but I think you might
have to go through a couple years of
their disappointment until they see the
success and I think that's just
something someday
that you guys will laugh about and if
they never do find it funny and they
never quite get that that's what you
liked and then they're just gonna have
to [ __ ] you know it's just one of
those things that you know your parents
aren't going to like everything that
you're doing but if you like it as long
as you're not this you know no I'm
talking about doing heroin it's just
something that they're gonna have to
[ __ ] accept that's all also would
like to know so definitely follow your
heart all right follow your heart man
because I think I think building custom
cars and everything is [ __ ] amazing
also what do you want to know your
thoughts on max first app and thanks I
love the guy I think you know if he
wasn't driving for Red Bull it means
there's a lot
guys if they had you know where the [ __ ]
did botas come from I mean he was good
and everything all the sudden get some
Mercedes and he's like the second best
guy out there it's just like Mercedes
throws so much money at the cars I mean
what do you think max Verstappen would
be doing if he was riding in a [ __ ]
Mercedes I think he would have way more
podiums and way more wins I think he's
an incredible driver and he I think he's
he's gonna be if he can get if he can
get with a team that has the [ __ ]
money
not like redbull is totally poor but I
feel like they're a distant third but
behind Mercedes and Ferrari even though
they're doing better than Ferrari this
year
as far as I know I've been kind of busy
but I think if he was driving a car
equivalent of that same thing as Daniel
Ricciardo I think there's a lot of guys
out there that could be which is a shame
and then you could really see some
incredible racing and I gotta be honest
with you I don't know if they need to
make the tracks [ __ ] wider or what
but they got to do something where these
guys actually have an opportunity to
pass each other because you know I
watched 17 to 19 laps of that 50-some
lap race and I just kept looking at the
distance between botas and in Lewis
Hamilton it just kept getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and it got up to close
to six seconds it's like I'm not [ __ ]
watching this I got my kid I'm gonna go
take my kid to the park forget it I
thought I was gonna see a race here it's
now you know it's just you can't compete
with it but I think obviously if max
Verstappen was was Ryan for like driving
for like a Mercedes or something like
that I mean I can't imagine what he's
been doing I love him I think he's great
he also he has balls - he seems mature
beyond his years he's not intimidated by
the press he's got a little that Kimi
räikkönen in him you know I like him I
think I'm a huge fan of his
all right feminist question a Billy
badass love the show I enjoy hearing you
and the lovely Nia on the podcast your
relationship dynamic is similar to mine
we were also an interracial couple
myself being a black woman me and my uni
and boyfriend have been together for
about five years and have different
approaches to life my passion and career
are one in the same
I'm constantly trying to move up and
make more my boyfriend just works for
money he indulges his passions in his
free time ie make him use it he doesn't
really pay attention to how much he
makes now that we're talking about
getting married friends and family don't
like the fact that I am more ahead in my
career and feel he should pull his
weight more exactly exactly you see that
you see that all the feminists out there
listening to this [ __ ] I'm telling you
there's that [ __ ] thing out there you
know it's like if a guy isn't bringing
home the bacon he's like he's just an
adult teenager what are we doing here
you can't make a baby you have an
ingredient but you know got the Easy
Bake Oven there so what are you doing
you got to make money my only problem
with and she says my only problem with
that is the situation was reversed and
he was making more than me no one would
care because he's a man exactly
sometimes I wish he made closer to what
I may make but it isn't a priority for
me in a relationship what are your
thoughts on this love the show and go
[ __ ] yourself well I don't think there
is a problem with it inherently what the
problem is is when you get pregnant and
you have to go on leave what kind of
sort of financial situation that puts
you in because for some reason I'm
assuming you live in the United States
is we don't give a [ __ ] if a woman's
pregnant we're like all right well you
just dropped off keep the caravan moving
you know there's some countries they get
upwards of six weeks off they also play
like 90 percent taxes that's the part
that they don't tell talk to you about I
I agree with everything you're saying
like if it was flipped they wouldn't say
anything about you
you know sometimes listen if you love
the guy [ __ ] marry the guy you know
if he's going to be a good dad and all
of that [ __ ] and you know if this is the
dynamic then make sure he doesn't blow
all the money he's making on music don't
squirrel away your money save your
[ __ ] money so that when you having
kids
you know it won't be a problem and then
have a number of kids that is conducive
to the money that you're making and I
think you can work it out you know and
don't forget to be nice to each other
all right I know that sounds easy but
you know you can just sort of just [ __ ]
and start taking somebody for granted
you'd be surprised how much a little
back rub goes either way you know
telling you all right the girl guys want
to [ __ ] but never want to date because
of big boobs okay what the [ __ ] is this
one going all right hey Bill Ania
I just turned twenty nine years old on
the 19th and although I should be
feeling great I've been a little bit
down about myself as of recently I ended
a five-year relationship three years ago
where I was a lot heavier I thought my
boobs were just bigger because of my
weight I've lost 50 pounds since then
and I look and feel great
however the boobs never left me I've
been on dates with some guys but nothing
has really come of it a lot of them just
wanted to hook up and that's not really
my style
for the first few dates I try to address
his modesty as I can I grew up in a
strict Catholic household so I try not
to show as much cleave as possible it's
really hard dressing comfortably without
looking like a church choir singer and
dying of heatstroke parentheses I live
in Arizona my girlfriends and I met up
for lunch a few days ago I'm the only
single friend without kids in the group
you know what I bet a lot of them Envy
you on a lot of days so before you get
too down on yourself there's this one
lady in the group who no one ever really
likes inviting because she's negative
and self-proclaimed blunt aka says rude
ass things just to say them they don't
even make sense oh yeah you got a sale
yeah he gay
blunt I would have used a different word
that rhymes with blunt anyway the
subject came up of me seeing someone I
mentioned how it's nothing serious the
girl then goes on this rant about how my
boobs make me look like our girls guys
just one
- wanna [ __ ] but never want a date she
said that she's pointed out that they
make me look easy and a funtime girl she
said girls with smaller boobs get taken
more seriously because guys get to know
her her personally with boobs in her
face they cannot yeah she's jealous of
you also they don't want to worry about
their friends staring I brushed it off
at first just thinking she was being a
[ __ ] but the more I think of it the
more it bugged me and kind of made sense
is this true no no it's not even
remotely true that's a [ __ ] she's a [ __ ]
alright and your friends just sat back
and just let her say that I gotta be
honest with you this sounds like you're
one of those real housewife dynamics
that I watched my wife watch and why I'm
just like why did [ __ ] would anybody
hang out with a person like that so we
just said something like that to you
don't you don't work that out the fact
that she said that and was that [ __ ]
rude in public and not thinking about
your feelings whatsoever
instead it in front of all your friends
dude [ __ ] her and in a lot of ways [ __ ]
your friends I don't know I don't know I
don't know I really should have near
here for this because that comes into
that [ __ ] female [ __ ] what you guys
are just you guys are rude and mean to
each other on a [ __ ] level that is
just like I don't even get I think it's
because you guys don't solve [ __ ]
physically the way guys do you know or
the threat because with the guy there's
always that thing in the back of the
head were you thinking like this person
can [ __ ] punch me in the face if I go
too far I gotta watch what I'm gonna say
and the fact that you guys don't have
that I you know I don't know um that
made me feel really sad for you none of
that is [ __ ] true all right guys who
just seeing for your boobs and we just
want to [ __ ] you it's you know your
boobs can actually help you because it
can help because there's other guys out
there they just mean that's just many
people just want to [ __ ] somebody else
they just want to [ __ ] them you know I
mean if you got the boobs you can see
where they're looking right so you can
you can speed date your titties are
helping you out
you know I just stay single until you
meet somebody that is worthy of you not
being single all right and I like the
fact that you don't hook up for a couple
to three dates that's a good [ __ ]
thing and I would really just you know
go out there and ask the questions you
want to ask and you know when you start
getting the answers you're looking for
that's the person that's worthy of your
time all right
don't hang out with any more blunt
[ __ ] people what a [ __ ] people can't
handle me because I just say things now
you're a [ __ ] all right finally push
back against sociopaths I'll spare you
all the wonderful praise and whatnot as
you probably get the point considering I
listen to the podcast
I threw hot wax into the face and suit
of the sociopath which has [ __ ] with
me and abused a friend slash lovely
ladies in my world threw hot wax is that
some young way of saying that you you
verbally trash this person are we
talking literally hot wax
I'll start by painting a picture of the
guy imagine a grizzled looking
flannel-wearing stocky guy with a
shit-eating grin standing about six foot
this guy is always such a [ __ ] in every
imaginable way he's incredibly
charismatic and that's what gets you
he's always sound so kind and loving but
underneath that is a manipulative
[ __ ] of the highest degree well
congratulations to you for figuring that
out tell that to his various exes which
he's done the following to them in soap
beat watched them slit their wrists on a
FaceTime call while not intervening at
all and then bragging about it to his
friends Jesus Christ the list goes on
and on a favorite quote of mine from him
is I enjoy making her feel worthless it
sounds like he's in the company of men
you ever seen that movie this [ __ ] is
deranged yet every month I hear the same
[ __ ] from everyone he's been a lot
better recently or he's improving or
whatever else [ __ ] people have been
saying the same thing for months
not years and I'm sick of it what is
worse is that he'll slip in the fact
that he has epilepsy in every possible
scenario he can yes it's a horrible
condition but all he does is talk about
his seizures from the past to garnish
sympathy points yeah okay this guy is
[ __ ] I will say the best thing and he
is interesting actual encounter starts
here to die I couldn't be around this
guy because I wouldn't want to kill this
guy this is the book we're closing with
uh with two [ __ ] one female one male
you mentioned the two of them had a
[ __ ] kid
Jesus actual encounter starts here I was
at the prom with my girlfriend and
decided to sit down with her during my
time walking through I decided to pick
up a little candle to hold for her and I
just because her and I and just because
why the hell not it provides a bit of
warmth a minute or so after I sat down
with her the [ __ ] blocks over and stands
in front of me bends down and blows it
out oh my god I'm starting to like this
guy what a [ __ ] dick I'm just
laughing because I'm not if I was you
dude I would IIIi was wondering how you
were gonna justify throwing hot wax now
I'm excited I'm excited now he go he
walks over and blows it out in front of
your girlfriend oh my god I'm not sure
what snapped in me maybe was the years
of him being demeaning to me and my
close friends at what but I just took
the candle and splashed all the hot boy
wax in it on his tuxedo and face pretty
much just throwing the [ __ ] on him oh my
god please describe how much he screamed
obviously I now look like a [ __ ]
wacko so I went to the bathroom with him
and spent the next 15 minutes picking
the [ __ ] out of his hair or not why did
you do that but I was parentheses and am
happy nonetheless dude you [ __ ] me out
of his reaction
I wanted to hear him scream like a girl
then you could have been Joe Pesci you
hear that is that a little girl down
there why the [ __ ] am I the only one who
will stand up to this piece of [ __ ] the
amount of times I've told them to not be
physical with smaller children because
they learned from that is unbelievable
was what I did warrant it at all
well if what you're saying is true
absolutely what wasn't warranted is you
cheating me and my listeners out of his
[ __ ] reaction I hate that you went to
the bathroom and helped him out god this
guy's got to be a good-looking son of a
[ __ ] well the obvious answer is no all
he did was blow your candle up no no no
no I'm agreeing with you dude this guy's
so manipulative he has you questioning
what you did let's look at the bigger
picture he's physically mentally abused
my friends me and his former partners
with little or no consequences thus far
the boy has to be put in his place at
one point or another thoughts regarding
my [ __ ] actions I think you need to
buy some more candles or stop hanging
out with the guy I love that you did it
I hate that you didn't describe his
scream and I also hate that you helped
him pick that he should have left him in
the [ __ ] bathroom to pick it out
himself and when he came over and been
like what the [ __ ] just be like what
well you should have just said you know
what was his quote um I I enjoy making
her feel worthless just be I'm sorry but
I just enjoy making you feel worthless
give him a taste of his own medicine
meanwhile cut this guy out of your life
just like the previous woman there's
people there's no reason to hang out
with people like this and there's two
reasons why people do this they either
grew up with that sort of dysfunctional
behavior so it seems normal to them so
as much as you leave your parents house
going up you know I'm not [ __ ]
repeating that you gravitate towards the
exact same abusive [ __ ] or you had such
a wonderful loving home that you go out
there like a babe in the woods and when
you you're just not even ready it's like
when they take an animal from one part
of the world and it sticks it into a
different part of the world and it
doesn't know what predators to look out
for and it's dead in the jungle within
[ __ ] three minutes anyways I love
that you threw wax on him good good feel
good on you all right I'm not advocating
anything like that but I'm glad that you
did it
but you know so I can cover myself in
case of lawsuit but that was phenomenal
I wouldn't help them I actually got
satisfied satisfaction out of that that
was what was missing from that previous
woman's story you know she stood dumped
her [ __ ] wine all over that [ __ ]
you know the chick with the small tits
[ __ ] ragging on her big tits alright
anyways that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check in on you on
Wednesday